the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
it's great to be back in the studio
today and i have a bunch of interesting
stories to talk to you about but
Leonardo DiCaprio the actor Leonardo
DiCaprio has made headlines because he
said recently that politicians who don't
believe in climate change should not
pull hold public office he said this at
the White House before the screening of
his new climate documentary quote the
scientific consensus in is in and the
argument is now over if you do not
believe in climate change you do not
believe in facts or in science or
empirical truths and therefore in my
humble opinion should not be allowed to
hold public office of course
conservatives are going nuts there's
basically two different ways in which
conservatives are flipping out about
this number one is the general actors
shouldn't talk about politics well he's
already sort of talking about politics
by making the documentary and I can't
imagine anybody with anybody would say
he doesn't have the right to make the
documentary so the general actors
shouldn't talk about politics I don't
know that that uh resonates with me at
all the other side of it is what do you
mean shouldn't be allowed to hold public
office if you don't believe in climate
change uh we don't have some kind of
thought police litmus test or if you
don't subscribe to certain views you're
just banned from being an elected
official and I I just don't think that
that's really at the root of what Leo
DiCaprio was saying here he's saying in
modern-day 2016 earth we know so much
about the science around climate change
and the effect of humans on earth that
it really doesn't make any sense that
someone who just denies the science
would ever get elected and how can we
possibly disagree with that if we are on
the side of science I know that there
are people in our audience who have
mixed feelings about whether they want
to hear about the actors that they likes
political views or the athletes that
they likes political views
quite frankly I am absolutely fine with
actors and athletes expressing their
political views if the format is correct
so an example is Al Michaels the famous
football play by play guide years ago
when John Kerry was running for
president during a Patriots game during
the broadcast there was a an overturned
call by the referees I believe it was
and al michaels said something to Ampera
phrasing here to the effect of well the
referees have flip-flopped on the call
and were definitely in the right state
for that of course referencing that the
game was in Massachusetts and that John
Kerry is from Massachusetts and that
John Kerry was being branded as a
flip-flopper I believe that that is not
appropriate you were being paid to be a
play-by-play commentator and two in a
completely unopposed and unbalanced way
make a critique what is effectively a
critique of John Kerry as a flip-flopper
on national TV when you're supposed to
be broadcasting football I'm completely
against that however I've heard Al
Michaels on the Howard Stern Show
talking about his politics and talking
about the fact that he is conservative
to to some degree and that's absolutely
fine and then people can decide do I now
enjoy al michaels is play-by-play
knowing that he's a Republican right
winger column what you will or do I not
enjoy it I never particularly loved al
michaels so for me it hasn't it it
certainly hasn't brought me over to
loving al michaels anymore but I don't
really care he can describe a football
game to me that's absolutely fine
another example is mel gibson who as we
know is is just by virulent lee
anti-semitic completely off-the-wall
father's a Holocaust denier etcetera he
was pulled over in santa monica by a
police officer and he started saying the
guy are you a Jew it just means it I
don't know what the odds are i can
imagine there's too many jewish police
officers in california but this the
police officer actually was jewish which
made the story even crazier uh and I
can't stand mel gibson and i've not
watched a Mel Gibson movie since and I
just won't it's completely off-putting
to me jon voight right Angelina Jolie's
father known as one of the few
Republicans in Hollywood I find the guy
vile and i also have been avoiding
movies that he's in is it possible that
there might be some movie that mel
gibson or jon voight
and that I just am so into seeing that I
will ignore the fact that I'm turned off
by their politics and see it sure but I
don't see any problem with people who
are in the entertainment world or the
athletic world telling us what their
views are and people can decide that
affects me or that doesn't affect me I
care about that or I don't what I do
sympathize with is sometimes when
someone you respect has political views
that don't align with yours I do
sometimes have this feeling of I would
have rather just not known because now I
have to choose to ignore their political
beliefs to remain a fan and this has
happened with some musicians there are
some right-wing musicians and I i'm now
not remembering who but there are some
right-wing musicians that whose music i
kind of like uh and you know i just have
to decide how much do i really like it
and and sort of go from there uh there's
a very interesting tweet that went out
which explains that the numbers of a new
voter registrations in florida are
heavily heavily skewed towards democrats
the Florida Democratic Party has
submitted 469 thousand voters
registration forms whereas the
Republican Party of Florida has
submitted only 59,000 voter registration
forms we have seen in recent State
polling that Hillary Clinton appears to
be ahead in Florida we have also seen
the revelations about Donald Trump doing
illegal business in Cuba during the
nineties which is not going to have a
positive impact on uh Cuban support for
Donald Trump in Florida so Florida is
really not looking good for Trump and
what a lot of people are aware of is
that Florida is already voting early
voting has started in Florida and if
this is this is just an if if we are
going to go by early or I'm sorry new
voter registrations in Florida it's very
hard to argue that Florida is looking
winnable for Donald Trump and then the
the sort of next extrapolation from that
is if you do a mock electoral map
and you give Florida to Hillary Clinton
it's pretty tough to build a realistic
path to 270 electoral votes for Donald
Trump so early Florida numbers at least
as far as new voters are heavily heavily
favoring hill hillary clinton and I
don't know I've not seen but maybe
there's some data available about the
early Florida voters I'm not sure uh I
don't know if there's any real way to
exit poll them because I I think I don't
know if they're voting in person or
voting absentee or how that works but it
would be interesting now a little more
than a month out from the election if we
could learn something about how these
early votes are are going in the state
of Florida so we'll keep an eye on that
uh another story I want to talk to you
about many people emailed me about this
I decided not to cover it on the regular
show just because it ended up just being
a tease about future news WikiLeaks
originally had scheduled Julian Assange
to give a sort of press conference from
the balcony of the embassy in London the
ecuadorian embassy where he's been now
for years and that was cancelled i
believe it was supposed to be yesterday
sometime within the last 24 to 48 hours
and it was scans cancelled because of
what was cited as specific security
concerns okay instead they made an
announcement saying that in the next ten
weeks they are going to be releasing
documents pertaining to google and the
US electoral system now question one are
they going to be releasing some
documents just about Google and then
some documents just about the US
electoral system or is the release going
to be about something that is uh
relating to both of these and the
speculation is that Google could be
could be working with one of the
candidates in the manipulation of search
results to send people hire results uh
on the first page first page search
results that could be more favorable or
more negative about a particular
candidate that's the general speculation
okay that's
number one number two Julian Assange has
been asked several times how do you
decide on the timing of when you release
documents and Julian Assange has said
numerous times we don't do the timing
thing we don't hold documents to then
release them at a time where it's going
to hurt someone or help someone or
whatever we just we get the documents we
go through them in terms of redacting
what needs to be redacted private
information and then we release them so
immediately a few people emailed me and
they said David ten weeks Julian Assange
is saying over the next ten weeks we're
going to be releasing this this means
that they have documents and they are
messing with the timing well maybe yeah
it's crossing my mind that that may be
the case although it is possible that
Julian Assange knows that they have the
documents but he doesn't know exactly
how long it will take to go through them
remove personal information redacted etc
so a ton of build up to this press
conference it had been billed as oh
there's an october surprise coming for
six or eight weeks we've been hearing
Julian Assange is going to put some
material out that is going to destroy
Hillary Clinton the press conference
initially gets cancelled then we have
the press conference not from the
balcony and we are told soon there will
be documents I know some right-wingers
who were basically done with this
they're not waiting around for Julian
Assange to do anything that's going to
help Hillary Clinton be defeated in
November and there are some
right-wingers that are still but sort of
hopeful I don't know what to expect the
expectation is being very very heavily
built up I actually know some Democratic
voters who were sort of but grudgingly
going to be voting for Hillary Clinton
in November who have told me you know
what I'm in a vote for Hillary because
Trump is nuts but if Julian Assange
releases something that just destroys
Hillary I would kind of applaud that I
would really be happy because ultimately
I really don't like Hillary Clinton so
people on the Left people on the right
many expectations about whether or not
we're going to get anything and my last
thought on this 10 weeks will get us
three weeks beyond the November election
and what would the point be if you're
waiting around for an october surprise
if it doesn't come out until november
20th they're really would be no point
and that would actually support Julian
Assange's claim that WikiLeaks doesn't
strategically release documents in order
to impact a particular election or
whatever we'll continue following it I
can assure you if and when these
blockbuster rule leaks happen we will
talk about them on the regular show one
other quick note yesterday I mentioned
we are debating internally whether to do
a david pakman show adult coloring book
instead of a calendar for 2017 or to do
a 20-17 calendar that instead of being
hey treat male themed is these comic
books comic strips developed by Dan
Burke a bunch of people emailing me
saying you know what you should do David
make it a calendar where the cartoons
can be colored in so if you want to use
it as a coloring book you can and if you
want to use it as a calendar you can
pretty solid idea I must say we just
have to see if we can do that uh and i
think but my sense is that coloring book
the texture of coloring book paper is
different than the texture of calendar
paper I think right Pat I mean on a
calendar usually it's like kind of
glossy I don't think glossy paper is
good for coloring I don't know i'm not
an expert in coloring books a little
more laminated i would say exactly yeah
yeah uh so anyway we're working on that
i'm more information about that soon I
whichever one we do i do want to make it
available within the next two weeks so
people have plenty of time before
january first to get their calendars
alright that's it for the bonus show we
have a great great show tomorrow and I
look forward to you joining
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com